et là c'est le drame c'est le weekend de
Pentecôte vous vous préparez à rentrer à
Nîmes pour la feria pour faire la fête
dans votre bodega et là on sonne à la
porte ding dong ding dong et je pensais
que c'était des potes mais c'était pas
des potes
moi tu as fermé ta loge tu as fermé ta
loge à clé là maintenant il y a il y a
la masseuse
comme un invité tu te rends compte ça
fait deux fois que je viens en tant
qu'inviter mais enfin je pense que je
vais aussi pour le blind test je vais
bien vous déchirer ah bon ah oui c'est
vrai que cette fois tu vas être ah oui à
la Baffie il a du souci à se faire là
c'est pas possible c'est benfic entre
Corti ce soir le blind test d'accord il
y a du boulot là je vais te vouvoyer moi
aussi on se voit d'accord alors Philippe
vous êtes ici pour un livre un livre qui
raconte votre vie qui s'appelle
autobiographie d'un DJ c'est publié chez
Ramsay belle éditeur avec une préface de
Frédéric Beigbeder où il raconte la fête
selon Corti alors il dit voilà les bras
les bras levaient les bras pas de bras
pas de chocolat comment tomber par terre
en se roulant des pelles comment
arracher sa chemise avec les horaires
sous les bras évidemment à cette
heure-là la corne de brume scratché avec
sa [ __ ] ce qui fait quand même le charme
des soirées de Philippe Corti il y a pas
que ça il y a la musique aussi il y a un
peu de musique aussi effectivement et la
conclusion millions de Frédéric BD dans
la préface de votre livre c'est le
problème quand on fréquente ce type
c'est qu'on a toujours mal à la tête le
lendemain et qu'on lui en veut jamais
c'est peut-être un détail pour vous mais
pour moi ça veut dire beaucoup voilà
France Gall
voilà alors moi j'ai fait la préface du
livre de Laurent Baffie je savais qui
s'appelle tu l'as dit ma fille je l'ai
jamais dit et Big BD a fait la préface
de ton lit il fallait que je choisisse
je trouvais que c'était un petit peu
embêtant de vous demander
vous demander de faire la préfecture
même sur des 45 tours petit parce qu'il
faut l'avoir depuis quand ça depuis
toujours eu scratcher avec sa [ __ ] c'est
ce que les gens adorent dans ces soirées
c'est vrai je suis performant très
performant
avec la [ __ ]
il y a un toucher il y a une il y a
c'est pour ça que j'aime le vinyle parce
que c'était
les doigts ils ont l'habitude de sentir
des trucs voilà faut connaître alors au
départ Philippe rien ne vous prédestiné
à cette vie pas vraiment vos parents
instituteurs peu mélomane c'est le moins
qu'on puisse en dire pour votre mère
vous dites dans votre bouquin verdiste
un drogué tout ce qui touchait à la
musique elle pensait que c'était un truc
qui arrivait de s'attendre donc
et pourtant votre premier billet de 10
francs vous a servi à vous acheter un
disque des Beatles un peu comme vous
tiens c'est assez vite
ouais c'était le double bleu
alors vous racontez votre enfant se
laisser veines la Corse la Camargue et
c'est dans l'école où vous habitez que
vous découvrez finalement le plaisir que
vous avez à faire plaisir aux élèves
j'étais un petit peu brimé parce que mon
père était donc mon instit et dès que
mec parler dans la classe c'est moi qui
ai dit donc j'avais pas vraiment le
droit de parler quoi au ceinturon
souvent en général je morflais souvent
mais je n'en veux pas parce que j'ai
tellement passé de super moments à
danser pour éviter les coups que
maintenant je suis pas trop mal pour
éviter ce genre de situation
tu te rends compte ça mène à tous
l'éducation nationale le droit surtout
ouais alors c'est encore pendant les
vacances avec votre cousin Daniel que
vous commencez à dîner oh non détruite
détruite
en fait on volait les truites que mon
père pêché pour aller les revendre pour
s'acheter des clopes à peu près normal
quand on a 10 ans on a envie de fumer
les cigarettes sont beaucoup moins cher
encore donc on avait un moyen qui était
pas trop con de se faire de l'argent
quoi on se mouille pas on piquait les
trucs de nos vieux et en plus elle
revendait à des cousins germains qui ont
balancé tout de suite l'histoire donc
voilà il y a une cousine là Yoko no
locale qui vous balance et votre père
vous ton alors c'était rigolo parce que
je pensais vraiment dérouiller ce
jour-là quoi et puis en fait sur le
chemin
non j'ai pas dérouillé il m'a dit juste
rentrer à la maison il m'a parlé encore
donc là j'ai compris que c'était assez
grand il m'a fait un soir c'était les
années 70 tout le monde avait les
cheveux sur les épaules et moi il m'a
rasé je rentre en 6e comme une brebis
pareil en 69 alors votre premier choc
c'est la mort de votre petit frère vous
dites ensuite la vie n'a jamais eu la
même saveur j'ai compris qu'il allait
falloir grandir seul c'est un peu non
c'est vrai je veux dire comme dans une
famille quand il y a un gamin qui meurt
surtout une famille corse ou on est
quand même vachement près des enfants ou
les enfants sont quand même c'est comme
le Maroc ou l'Algérie les gens les gens
sont très proches des gamins quand un
petit disparaît c'est difficile pour les
parents de refaire surface donc nous on
a eu l'habitude après de vivre un petit
peu sans nos parents quoi ils étaient un
petit peu parti avec lui c'est que mais
c'est en même temps c'est pas plus mal
parce que ça m'a permis de grandir tout
seul alors peu à peu vous vous trouvez
d'abord votre volonté d'être célèbre
vous en prenez conscience rapidement et
ensuite le pouvoir du DJ c'est-à-dire
que rapidement vous comprenez que le
disquaire comme on disait à l'époque
c'est le maître du monde quoi
auprès de mettre du monde parce que
c'est un métier j'allais dire de
fainéantir on n'est pas obligé de faire
de la musique on joue celle des autres
et on récolte tous les honneurs alors
quand elle est bien distillée dans la
soirée c'est une arme fatale qu'on peut
arriver à mener les gens à peu près où
on veut alors votre première boîte en
tant que propriétaire c'est la scatola
hein parce que bon vous avez eu un
enfant qui s'appelle Camille vous dites
il faut quand même que voilà il faut
trouver 50 000 balles avec votre pote
Christian vous achetez la scatola à
Port-Camargue et c'est là que vous
rencontrez Christian Lacroix qui a été
très important pour vous et le premier
finalement la croix qui s'est aperçu de
votre talent pour la fête quoi c'est le
premier qui m'a permis d'avoir une vraie
crédibilité j'allais dire parisienne
c'était un créateur qui était en vogue
dans le monde entier et c'est grâce à
lui que j'ai pu rencontrer des gens qui
m'ont fait travailler à New York San
Francisco un peu partout c'est vrai
voilà mais c'est Mourousi qui va vous
propulser au sommet un jour vous le
rencontrez comment manger je sors d'une
fête mémorable à ce scatola j'ai j'ai un
casque à pointe à la dans la tête mais
alors terrible
on disait qu'il était au moins
j'ai dit donc il me plante encore une
deuxième fois le mec et puis finalement
non il me dit non non j'ai une grosse
fête dans les arènes et c'est vrai que
là j'ai une offre une soirée magique il
vous propose un animé la fête de son
mariage dans les arènes de Nîmes songe
avec Véronique
25000 personnes c'est l'apogée de votre
ville quand vous arrivez c'est le climax
quand vous arrivez dans les arènes c'est
le début d'une histoire parce qu'après
on a vu tout ce qui s'est passé avec le
DJ la médiatisation on peut grâce à
grâce à vous et à ce qui s'est passé
après mais moi j'ai eu ce choc là alors
que les gens ont joué toujours dans des
boîtes devant 400 personnes comme quand
on a filé les manettes de la soirée je
vous garantis que si j'ai pas un verre
de cognac pour rentrer je rentre pas
j'ai j'ai vraiment peur quoi quand je
sors du bout du bourlader en fait dans
les gradins des arènes et je vois ces
25000 personnes qui se lèvent parce que
j'ai ma tronche qui arrive sur un écran
géant et les mecs attendent depuis deux
heures quoi il y a une rumeur qui montre
des arènes où je me dis bon il a il faut
donc je prends la bouteille de cognac
j'envoie une je me dis faut y aller quoi
voilà alors après il y a le dis à Paris
avec Etienne rodagil paix à son âme si
tu nous regardes
Vanessa Paradis Christine Bravo
Christian Lacroix Frédéric Beigbeder et
moi comme assistant DJ au 17 octobre
ensuite il y a cet article de Big bene
dans la presse qui vous lance les Bains
Douches et puis vous relancer le papa
caillot à Saint-Tropez ouais et là c'est
le drame voilà c'est le weekend de
Pentecôte vous vous préparez à rentrer à
Nîmes pour la feria pour faire la fête
dans votre bodega et là on sonne à la
porte ding dong ding dong et je pensais
que c'était des potes mais c'était pas
des potes j'ai trois pandores en tenue
les gendarmes
et les mecs me bon menottes me jette par
terre mais c'est terrible ils vous font
traverser Saint-Tropez 600 mètres
menotté
qu'ils étaient en train de faire un truc
donc moi je voyais pas vraiment
l'intérêt d'autant d'autant plus que
même à l'époque ils peuvent venait son
frère aussi on n'essaye pas de mouiller
les autres
mais bon je sens pas je sens pas la
tempête arriver parce que j'ai pas grand
chose à me reprocher et si ce n'est si
ce n'est d'en prendre voilà ce soir
mettre les choses au clair c'est quoi
l'histoire ce que ce que dit
l'accusation c'est que vous avez relancé
le papa Gaillon
en attirant les stars avec de l'exta
alors moi comme les stars venaient bah
le bon peuple venait et ça rapportait
beaucoup d'argent à tout le monde voilà
ça c'est la version c'est la version
c'est la preuve qu'ils ont trouvé pour
me condamner à 4 ans de prison 4 ans de
prison
dans un dossier quand on dit oui
effectivement il y a beaucoup toutes les
stars venaient parce que vous leur
donniez de la drogue alors moi je veux
bien mais il faut quand même interroger
les stars ils ont jamais interrogé les
stars mais non ils ont fait style qu'ils
avaient pas trouvé ces papiers
l'histoire c'est quoi alors moi on dit
je fais 96 heures de garde à vue quand
même c'est pas c'est pas rien c'est 4
jours enfermés dans un cachot de 3
mètres carrés où il y a des excréments
partout où on a pas de matelas ou il y a
une carte comme ça c'est à dire que moi
je suis prêt à dire que ma mère couche
avec Orlando s'il faut qu'elle vende la
jusqu'à la sortie des lycées pour sortir
juste pour qu'on me parle et c'est vrai
ou pas
qu'on me dise bon allez sortie
mettez-vous un petit pot au jour où les
mecs me sortent 4 fois en 4 jours quoi
donc 4h je suis déposition elle est
comme ça ils savent déjà depuis le
départ que il y a pas grand chose contre
moi ils arrivent à un point où on leur
demande de clôturer un dossier qui est
là depuis 87 ou 88 pour une barrette de
shit et cinq extasie et puis le mec dit
oui effectivement j'ai le papa Gaillot
et quand j'en ai vendu à Corti et moi ce
mec là je l'ai chopé deux trois jours
avant parce qu'il m'avait vendu 5 piles
de la bronzée donc je lui dis tes
extasies c'était 5000 la bronzés donc je
lui mets une rouste effectivement le mec
se fait arrêter 5 jours après il dit
mais moi je l'ai vendais et Corti me
protéger donc moi je me fais ces 96
heures de garde à vue je suis déféré au
parquet de Toulon je suis pas le juge
d'instruction à ce moment-là s'il y a
vraiment des faits concordants si vous
êtes un dealer il vous enferme n'est-ce
pas repartir à Saint-Tropez moi le mec
me dit bon ben rentrer chez vous donc je
retourne à Saint-Tropez et déjà dans la
presse
il y a le dealer de la Jet 7 interpellé
d'instruction
au cul la mouche c'est à dire que déjà
on va fou plein de principes qui
devraient pas être bafoués dans notre
dans notre public alors je me retrouve
devant une campagne de presse
phénoménale c'est-à-dire je suis le
dealer la jet-set j'en ai donné à
Barclay j'en ai donné à tous les gens
qui venaient chez moi c'est terrible
cette histoire j'avais été un petit peu
le bouc émissaire du truc quoi voilà en
plus j'arrivais un moment où c'était
c'était bien de faire un exemple puis
voilà non mais en même temps je suis pas
du tout rancunier je trouve que je
trouve que les mecs n'ont pas fait leur
boulot ils savaient qu'il faisait pas
leur boulot ce qui s'est passé quand
même qu'il faut raconter c'est qu'à
l'époque avant entre le moment où vous
étiez condamné le monde vous étiez là en
tôle il y a eu un moment où vous avez
besoin de travailler moi j'ai fait
travailler Philippe et tu t'en souviens
il y a la mairie de Saint-Tropez qui
écrit à Hervé Bourges président de
d'Antenne 2 à l'époque et qui dit
Ardisson fait travailler un repris de
justice un marchand de drogue etc et moi
je suis allé voir Bourges qui est un
homme admirable la preuve c'est qu'il a
dit bon si il est
il faut faire travailler bien sûr moi ce
qui m'a gêné dans cette histoire Thierry
c'est pas tellement le fait de faire de
faire de la prison mais c'est le fait
qu'on met coller une étiquette qui était
pas la mienne voilà donc c'est toujours
un merdant pour tel le chapeau qui ne va
pas ça fait mal à la tête et le côté
fils d'instituteur a dû ressorti ça doit
être terrible c'est vous avez été élevé
quand même dans une certaine morale donc
d'un seul coup se retrouver à la une des
journaux comme Le Marchand de drogues ça
doit être parce que c'est un truc auquel
on n'est pas préparé aux parents ils ont
pris ça comment ma mère et mon père ont
été très affectés par par l'histoire pas
simplement par le fait que que je sois
obligé d'aller en prison mais ils ont
été affectés par le fait qu'ils étaient
obligés pendant des années d'expliquer
une république et que c'était pas
celle-là quand le il se retrouvait
devant quelque chose qui on les avait
trompé encore une fois donc ils ont vécu
ça il y a eu il y a eu beaucoup plus
fiages parce que le fils partait en
prison et le deuxième parce que pendant
des années ils avaient défendu des
valeurs qui qui ne reconnaissaient plus
voilà la présence vous avez fait de la
muscu ouais musculation masturbation
télévision un truc qui était terrible
non j'ai fait de la muscu je me suis
reposé
[Musique]
non mais c'était bien parce qu'en plus
après j'ai fait une équipe vidéo qui
sortait filmer les joueurs de foot donc
on sortait souvent donc on se préparait
à notre réinsertion j'allais dire mais
il y a pas que ça qui m'a aidé à tenir
en prison je veux dire il y a des il y a
d'autres choses il y a l'amour il y a
l'amour de mes gosses il y a l'amour de
la femme que qui était avec moi il y a
l'amour de gens comme vous parce que on
la passe je l'ai pas souvent dit parce
que j'ai pas eu l'occasion de le dire
mais à une époque où l'avenir pour moi
était assez sombre c'est-à-dire que je
suis de chauffe un trou je suis pas
comment je vais sortir si je vais sortir
à moitié bien ou pas bien du tout moi
convoque c'est le juge d'instruction et
on me dit
vous avez un contrat de travail mais je
suis pas dans l'état de sortir même si
j'ai un contrat de travail je peux pas
sortir et c'est vous qui me l'avez
envoyé voilà
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu